le soir oui ça la veille de housses
balance les vidéos geismar kim abeilles
qui me renvoie premièrement une capture
d'écran ou là je vois la vidéo qui
supprime directement donc là on peut se
dire que vraiment ils montée
d'adrénaline arrive je me dis qu'est-ce
que je vais faire comme moi je le faire
comme moi je la touche à mes parents et
et là ce moment-là je me dis bah c'est
quoi pose-toi il m'a dit on se revoit
demain pour en parler qu'ils allaient
avoir la personne au téléphone et je me
suis dit mais en fait non j'ai pas envie
de passer au téléphone avec untel untel
est en fait c'est pas les enchères ou
encore n'est pas les enchères cette
vidéo n'est pas les enchères en fait est
arrivé à un moment donné je me suis
posée j'ai contacté mais de grand frère
jared j'écoute il s'est passé ça ça ça
ça à telle période j'ai appelé ma mère
judy écoute ya un truc qui va sortir
c'est moi qui va le faire parce qu'en
fait il y en a assez arrive à un moment
donné parce que vous en aviez marre du
chantage ou a dit je fais sortir moi
même la vidéo terminé exactement c'est
voilà maintenant que je veux me faire
peur avec ça bahia personnes qui me fait
peur et j'ai balance moi même en fait
ouais c'est ça oui il va y arriver mais
il ya un phénomène qui s'appelle le
revenge porn dont on entend de plus en
plus parler et il faut dire à toutes les
jeunes filles qui nous regardent ce soir
et tous les jeunes garçons parce que ça
peut aussi arriver à des cadets garçons
ne cédez pas mais d'abord surtout ne
faites pas ne fait pas ses fameuses
vidéos puisque en souriant sarhadi tout
le monde l'a fait tout le monde le fait
grave arrêter de banaliser ce truc là et
justement ça peut être extrêmement
dangereux savent aujourd'hui c'est un
phénomène qui revient qui peut revenir
en boomerang à des gamines de 12 13 14
ans à qui on demande d'enlever le
t-shirt à qui on demande de se montrer
en petite culotte et c'est ça peut
l'employer la ville hors
normes et conventions histoire ça au
départ quand marc vous appelle on est
vous avez dit non vous avez réussi à
convaincre l'homme qui vous avez filmé
de ne pas diffuser ces vidéos en fait
avant que marc vampa cette personne là
étaient venus directement à moi essayer
de me soutirer de l'argent pour sortir
ces vidéos ça n'a pas marché parce que
je lui ai dit concrètement je vais pas
te mentir c'est c'est pas du tout en
fait tu vas me détruire on va dire que
clairement ça va me détruire ma famille
y aura la honte je lui dis mais c'est
quoi le suit en fait c'est pas la
première fois que ça se passe et qu'en
fait une fois de plus une fois de plus
une fois de plus un moment donné bah je
vais faire des choses vis-à-vis de moi
ou jean ou en fait j'ai honte de moi
alors que je devrais pas louis j'ai
parlé du suicide je vais parler de
suicide tu sais que ça peut aller très
loin ses histoires ça peut me déprime et
ça peut aller vraiment très long et de
la balle à personne elle a un peu
compris elle s'est calmée pendant
quelques mois et je lui dis surtout que
un moment vous avez hésité à lui donner
les 50000 euros pas du tout j'avais ou
pas du tout je vais et je vais pas vous
mentir je préfère me mettre dans le mal
moi que donner quelque chose à quelqu'un
parce qu'en vrai
qu'elle mérite en fait ça veut dire
qu'elle aura gagné tout ce que en fait
tout ce qu'elle est a voulu alors à
gagner je donne 50000 euros à elle elle
envoie la vidéo à quelqu'un d'autre
c'est comme en avait 10 personnes
derrière nom paraît que vous avez pensé
au pire à ce moment là ouais ouais
vraiment mais vraiment vous êtes dit ma
vie est foutue vraiment s'est passé mais
c'est ma vie est foutue parce que c'est
une honte je suis on va pas se mentir
maintenant moi je suis on va pas je suis
leur but on va parler français je suis
heureux que chez nous c'est un truc de
ouf en vrai de vrai c'est un truc de ouf
et en fait quand il sait pas assez sage
et des grands frères je suis la petite
dernière chez la fille je me suis dit ok
d'accord peut-être c'est moi camardes et
et tu peux penser il ya plusieurs
personnes qui pensent comme vous qui se
dit mais pourquoi s'est laissé filmer
mais en fait
alors je vais très très clair je
n'aurais vous dis je sais pas vous là
c'est pas vous qui devait avoir honte en
ouais mais vous vous êtes fait des films
et et peut importer ses pas et c'est pas
grave si on décide de le faire on décide
de le faire ce lieu qui doit avoir honte
c'est celui qui ensuite décident
d'exploiter ces vidéos une fois que la
relation est terminée vraiment en soyons
très très clairs là dessus non je
préviens simplement des petites jeunes
filles de faire attention parce que
voilà la vidéo de son corps c'est
toujours alors oui j parallèlement à
cette diffusion courageux de la vidéo
est ce que vous avez donc vous avez
diffusé la vidéo et que quand ils font
rage et vos parents vos frères bats au
final au début c'était réticence à me
disait de ne pas mettre la vidéo et que
si elles sortaient de de ne pas donner
l'heure à cette personne ne pas relever
sur les réseaux mais en fait j'ai dit
que non et le lendemain quand je les
fais pas ma mère a été contente ma mère
a été content parce qu'elle m'a dit
aujourd'hui tu parles pas que pour toi
mj tu parles avec avec des millions de
filles parce qu'il ya des gens
ralentissent en fait il ya des gens dans
leur tête ils se rendent pas compte des
heures qui a derrière c'est à dire que
moi encore ça va j'ai une famille cool
mais si tu as une conne famille
complètement chtarbé qui rentre chez toi
qui te met des coups qui te ramène à
l'hôpital on fait comment sita à 6,6 à
ce moment là qu avec un mari qui est
complètement impulsif qui frappe sa
femme et qui voit sa sur les réseaux
c'est comment